pas facile de surprendre sandrine gruda
à 31 ans la martiniquaise est la joueuse
la plus expérimentée des bleus la
deuxième basketteuses la plus capé de
l'équipe de france avec 175 sélection
elle collectionne également les
médailles depuis ses débuts le pivot des
bleus prend à coeur son rôle de leader
j'ai toujours su ce statut en fait quand
je regarde bien que ce soit dans mes
débuts à l'ancienne que par la suite à
quatre bornes
j'ai été leader quoi donc franchement je
ça va c'est une habitude en fait je
dirais sandrine débute à 18 ans par
valenciennes puis direction la russie à
ekaterinbourg elle remporte 2 euroligues
est pas moins de six titres de
championne de russie après plusieurs
saisons états unis et en italie
la martiniquaise s'est imposé comme le
green naturel de la nouvelle équipe des
bleus aux championnats du monde
c'est la première année j'ai souvent
contre des jeunes
mais c'est vrai que là cette année du
coup il y en a quand même un certain
nombre et et c'est bien parce que
j'apprends justement beaucoup de
fraîcheur à cette équipe et nous de
notre côté on apporte le plus
d'expérience donc c'est intéressant
chose que ça fait un beau mélange
sandrine gruda va rejoindre italie son
club sio l'ancienne joueuse du goldeneye
n apportera dans la péninsule italienne
son expérience